bien mesdames et messieurs comme je m'y
étais engagé la semaine dernière
je reviens vers vous pour vous présenter
épaulé par plusieurs membres du
gouvernement
les premiers axes de la stratégie
vaccinale adoptée par la france
un mot au préalable sur la situation
sanitaire de notre pays qui s'améliore
progressivement la circulation du virus
continue de reculer de semaine en
semaine
le nombre de cas positifs diminué nous
pourrions dans les jours à venir passer
sous la barre des 10000 cas quotidiens
en moyenne
en conséquence la pression sur les
hôpitaux s'allège progressivement nous
comptions hier soir 3488 personnes
hospitalisées en réanimation et je veux
inlassablement redire ma vive
reconnaissance à nos professionnels de
santé la france est aujourd'hui le pays
d'europe où la baisse de la pression
épidémique a été la plus forte et la
plus rapide
c'est le fruit des efforts de chacune et
chacun d'entre vous qui avait respecté
les règles sanitaires et je tiens à
nouveau à vous en remercier
c'est aussi le résultat de notre
stratégie de freinage avec le couvre-feu
d'abord puis le confinement ces mesures
ont été je le sais bien dur pour nombre
d'entre vous mais elle était nécessaire
et reste encore nécessaire car la
situation reste fragile
le niveau de circulation du virus est le
nombre de personnes en réanimation reste
ainsi supérieurs à ce qu'ils étaient
en mai dernier lorsque nous avons des
confiné nous ne sommes pas encore venu à
bout de ce virus et nous devons rester
mobilisés dès demain les lieux de culte
à la suite de la décision du conseil
i d'état et des discussions fructueuses
que le ministre de l'intérieur et moi
même avons conduite avec leurs
représentants pour en accueillir les
fidèles avec une règle d'un siège sur
trois
et d'une rangée sur deux est ce le temps
du confinement ce confinement va encore
durer deux semaines avant l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle phase d'assouplissement
le 15 décembre prochain
si la tendance actuelle se poursuit
et donc si nous restons vigilants nous
passerons alors vous le savez un régime
de couvre feu de 21 heures à 6 heures du
matin sauf pour les réveillons des 24 et
31 décembre
les déplacements seront autorisés sur la
france entière sans attestation pendant
la journée
plusieurs activités notamment dans le
champ de la culture pourront reprendre
dans le respect des protocoles
sanitaires strictes
cette nouvelle étape sera encore marquée
par des règles de grande prudence
c'est pourquoi les activités entraînant
le plus de risques notamment parce
qu'elle favorise le brassage et la
concentration de populations où qu'elles
ne permettent pas le port du masque en
continu resteront fermés nous les
accompagnerons par des mesures
économiques qui ont été renforcées nous
ne sortirons de cette crise que si nous
avançons par étapes et avec prudence
gardons en mémoire la réalité du risque
d'un rebond de l'épidémie c'est ce que
nous avons connu cet été
c'est ce que tous les pays autour de
nous ont vécu il faut à tout prix éviter
de revivre ce scénario à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année parce que c'est une
période propice aux regroupements
nous devons être ensemble attentif et
solidaire pour écarter ce risque d'un
recompte finement quelques semaines plus
tard
voyez que des états unis qui était déjà
dans une situation sanitaire difficile
redoutent actuellement une flambée de
nouveaux cas après le relâchement
observé lors des fêtes de thanksgiving
comme nous l'avons souhaité avec le
président de la république
vous pourrez retrouver vos proches pour
les fêtes de fin d'année pour passer ces
moments précieux en famille ou entre
amis mais cela ne veut pas dire que nous
pourrons fêter noël ou nouvel an comme
les années précédentes
il nous faudra respecter les gestes
barrière est toujours veillé à protéger
les plus fragiles en particulier nos
aînés la plupart de nos voisins
européens ont fixé un nombre maximum de
convives à réunir pour ces réveillons
allant de 6 à 10 personnes
or enfants selon les pays il nous paraît
raisonnable de vous recommander une
jauge de six adultes sans compter les
enfants
nous avons saisi le haut conseil de
santé publique pour précisé les
préconisations complémentaire de
prudence qu'il sera hautement
souhaitable de respecter et l'avis est
attendu en début de semaine prochaine
ces résultats doivent être consolidées
et nous permettre d'envisager l'avenir
avec plus d'optimisme
cet optimisme est renforcé par le
lancement très prochain de la campagne
de vaccination contre la copie 19
l'arrivée du vaccin est une étape très
importante dans notre combat collectif
contre l'épidémie c'est une arme
supplémentaire à notre disposition qui
va nous permettre de mieux nous protéger
la mobilisation exceptionnelle de tous
les acteurs français et mondiaux de la
science et de la recherche médicale a
permis de développer ses premiers
vaccins dans des délais rapides ce qui
nous permettra d'entamer la campagne de
vaccination environ un an après
l'apparition du virus
pour autant ce délai qui peut sembler
bref au regard de la durée habituelle de
développement d'un vaccin ne signifie en
aucun cas que nous nous serions
précipitée au détriment d'un sécurité
sanitaire c'est le fruit d'une
mobilisation inédite et exceptionnelle
de toute la communauté scientifique
mondiale
pour répondre à cette pandémie elle-même
inédite et exceptionnelle
cet effort de recherche sans précédent à
apporter sur plusieurs centaines de
projets fondés sur des approches ou des
techniques scientifiques différentes
si tous ces projets n'aboutiront
évidemment pas beaucoup ont avancé
suffisamment pour constituer des
candidats sérieux dont certains sont
engagés dans leur première phase
d'essais cliniques
nous entendrons dans un instant le
professeur d'immunologie alain fischer
qui nous présentera les différents
vaccins en cours de développement
leurs différences technologiques et
médical ainsi que les processus
d'évaluation qui précède ce qu'on
appelle leur autorisation de mise sur le
marché dans les tout prochains jours et
en toute hypothèse avant le 29 décembre
prochain
l' agence européenne du médicament se
prononcera sur l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché des deux premiers vaccins
est plus avancée le vaccin faille their
bio ntech et le vaccin moderne
cette autorisation européenne obtenue
c'est une autorités sanitaires
françaises
la haute autorité de santé qui se
prononcera ses étapes constituent des
garanties indispensables pour commencer
à nous faire vacciner en france je sais
que les questions que vous vous posez
sont nombreuses et c'est normal est ce
que ces vaccins sont sûrs
est-ce qu'ils sont efficaces y en
aura-t-il assez pour tout le monde qui
sera prioritaire pour l'accès aux
premiers vaccins où pourra-t-on se faire
vacciner et par qui est certainement
bien d'autres questions encore nous
essaierons de répondre à ces questions
qui sont toutes importantes et légitimes
certaines dépens de décision d'autorité
scientifique indépendante française ou
européenne
ainsi la décision d'autoriser ou non un
vaccin ne relève pas directement du
gouvernement mais appartient aux
autorités scientifiques indépendantes
qui sont en charge de l'évaluation des
produits de santé
autre exemple le choix des personnes qui
devront être vaccinés en priorité
n'incombe pas au gouvernement mais à la
haute autorité de santé qui s'est
d'ailleurs prononcée en début de semaine
sur la base d'une expertise indépendante
que nous entendons évidemment respecter
quelle est la responsabilité de l'état
est bien que tout vaccin mis sur le
marché et bien reçu toutes les
autorisations nécessaires pour assurer
la sécurité sanitaire des français de
garantir que les vaccins autorisés
arrive rapidement et dans le cadre d'une
logistique efficace
elle est aussi que l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé concernés soient
mobilisés dans le champ de leurs
compétences
le rôle de l'état c'est également que
les publics prioritaires puissent
accéder aux vaccins dans des conditions
de simplicité de sécurité de
transparence qui préserve notamment leur
capacité à savoir et donc à décider le
début de la vaccination est désormais
une question de semaines mais nous nous
préparons depuis déjà plusieurs mois à
cette échéance
notre premier objectif a été de garantir
que la france disposera de suffisamment
de vaccins
le moment venu c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous y sommes pris très en
avance plusieurs candidats vaccins
avaient été identifiés d'un juin comme
ayant des chances de réussite
et dès le printemps dernier la france
avait proposé à ses partenaires
européens d'acquérir ces vaccins
ensemble pour peser plus fort dans les
négociations
avec les laboratoires et pour éviter la
logique du premier arrivé premier servi
une task force européenne a ainsi été
mise en place dès juin dernier pour
acquérir ces vaccins un remarquable
travail a été conduit au niveau européen
qui a aujourd'hui permis de signer six
contrats d'approvisionnement et qui se
poursuit il témoigne de la capacité des
partenaires européens à unir leurs
efforts et leurs compétences au bénéfice
des citoyens européens
grâce à ce travail les prix sont les
mêmes pour tous les pays les vaccins
livrés à chaque pays arrive au même
moment et pour des quantités fixées au
prorata de la population des états soit
15 % pour la france
la france disposera ainsi d'un potentiel
de 200 millions de doses ce qui
permettrait de vacciner 100 millions de
personnes puisque le vaccin nécessite à
ce jour deux injections à quelques
semaines d'intervalle
c'est plus que nos besoins ce dock temps
que tout le monde ne souhaitera pas être
vaccinés mais c'est la marge de sécurité
que nous prenons car certains des
vaccins en cours de développement
pourraient ne pas obtenir in fine et
leur autorisation et qu'un taux de
pertes doit être prise en compte
or comme je les dis notre premier
objectif est de garantir que la france
ait suffisamment de vaccins pour sa
population est évidemment et c'est un
autre atout des négociations conduites
au niveau européen nous ne paierons à la
fin que ce qui nous sera effectivement
livrés la vaccination sera gratuite pour
tous et le gouvernement a budgété à
cette fin 1,5 milliard d'euros dans le
budget de la sécurité sociale pour 2021
agnès pannier une hache et clément bonne
préciseront tout à l'heure cette
stratégie d'acquisition des vaccins
ça c'est le
premier objectif à voir les quantités
suffisantes notre deuxième objectif est
de vacciner en priorité les personnes
pour lesquelles le virus de la corrida
le plus dangereux c'est un impératif de
santé publique
une dizaine de vaccins devraient arriver
sur le marché entre fin décembre et cet
été mais comme je lai indiqué seuls deux
d'entre eux seront disponibles au mieux
dès les premiers jours dès les derniers
jours de décembre
sinon à partir de janvier tout le monde
ne pourra donc pas se faire vacciner
immédiatement dans son avis publié lundi
la haute autorité de santé a établi un
ordre très précis des populations à
vacciner
elle nous recommandent de vacciner
d'abord les personnes âgées en
établissement notamment les ehpad à la
fois les résidents et les personnels
travaillant lorsque ces derniers sont à
risque de développer une forme grave de
la maladie par exemple lorsqu'ils sont
diabétiques
cela représente environ un million de
personnes ce qui correspond au camp dit
et de vaccins qui nous seront livrés au
cours du premier mois
c'est la phase une de notre stratégie
puis au fur et à mesure des livraisons
nous élargirons le périmètre de la
vaccination en commençant par les près
de 14 millions de personnes présentant
un facteur de risque liée à l'âge ou à
une pathologie chronique et ainsi que
par certains professionnels de santé
c'est la phase 2 de notre stratégie qui
devrait commencer en février et
s'étendra jusqu'au printemps
enfin comme l'a annoncé le président de
la république nous ouvriront
progressivement à partir du printemps la
vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population ce sera la phase 3 de notre
stratégie
le ministre chargé de la santé olivier
veyrat on reviendra plus en détail sur
chacune des phases en fait vous l'avez
compris le déploiement de la vaccination
se fera progressivement suivant une
logique simple priorité sera donnée aux
publics les plus vulnérables au virus
les plus susceptibles de développer des
formes graves de la maladie
notre troisième objectif est donc de
construire une logistique adaptée à ce
défi majeur de la vaccination acheminer
des millions de vaccins
certains avec des caractéristiques très
particulières le vaccin said there doit
par exemple être conservées à moins 80
degrés est en effet une opération d'une
très grande complexité
nous y travaillons aussi depuis
plusieurs mois nous avons acheté le
matériel et les équipements nécessaires
et nous serons prêts pour les premières
vaccinations
dès que les vaccins seront disponibles
notre quatrième et dernier objectif il
est de construire une stratégie
vaccinale qui répondent à trois
impératifs la sécurité la transparence
et la proximité
premier impératif je l'ait déjà évoqué
la sécurité
je sais et j'entends les réticences
voire parfois les craintes exprimées par
certains d'entre vous je veux rappeler
que si un vaccin est autorisée
c'est au terme d'une procédure
rigoureuse d'essai et d'évaluation
conduits par des autorités sanitaires
indépendante
nous ne démarreront rien sans l'avis
préalable de la haute autorité de santé
sur chaque des vaccins et les personnes
vaccinées seront suivies dans le cadre
d'un dispositif renforcé de
pharmacovigilance et de traçabilité mis
en place par l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et l'assurance
maladie
deuxième impératif la transparence je
souhaite que les français aient accès à
toute l'information dont nous
disposerons nous mêmes c'est pourquoi
notre stratégie vaccinale sera présenté
au parlement dans le cadre d'un débat
prévu par l'article 51 de la
constitution au cours de ce mois
je m'engage à ce que durant toute la
campagne la vaccination
toute la transparence toute la pédagogie
soit faite sur les décisions que nous
prendrons
et sur l'organisation que nous mettrons
en place le président de la république a
voulu que les citoyens puissent avoir
connaissance des débats scientifiques
qu'ils puissent dialoguer avec les
experts et nous aider à être plus
pertinent
plus clair plus attentifs à vos
préoccupations
j'ai saisi à cet effet le conseil
économique et social environnemental
afin qu'il organise et anime c'est son
rôle l'association de la société civile
et des citoyens à la conception et au
suivi de notre stratégie vaccinale les
collectivités territoriales seront
également partie prenante temps à
l'élaboration de cette stratégie qu
modalités de son déploiement
ce qui fait le lien avec la proximité
je crois profondément que la confiance
passe d'abord par la place que nos
professionnels de santé qui aideront
dans notre stratégie vaccinale en
particulier et il est souhaitable que le
médecin généraliste soit au coeur du
dispositif et en particulier le médecin
traitant et plus généralement c'est par
l'implication d'un maximum d'acteurs de
terrain dans les territoires que passera
la réussite de la vaccination surtout à
partir de la phase 2 chacun doit pouvoir
se faire vacciner par un professionnel
de santé à côté de chez lui qu'il
connaît et en qui il a confiance je sais
tout de suite la parole au professeur
alain fischer professeur d'immunologie
et chercheur en biologie qui va vous
préciser ce que nous savons sur le
processus de sélection et d'évaluation
que ces vaccins ont suivi pour être
autorisées et sur les modalités que nous
instaurerons pour garantir le plus haut
niveau de pharmaco vigilance
monsieur le professeur
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres comme
vous venez de le dire très justement la
vaccination représente un espoir énorme
on peut le dire ainsi pour arriver
progressivement à contrôler cette
pandémie qui a provoqué autant de morts
et autant de souffrances de parlements
des spécifiquement en france les
nouvelles qui sont arrivées de par les
industriels qui ont développé les
premiers vaccins au décours des études
cliniques d'efficacité et de sécurité au
cours de ces deux trois dernières
semaines sont sur ce plan encourageantes
et même dans une certaine mesure nous
ont surpris par la qualité des résultats
donc j'avais brièvement les évoqué mais
avant les évoquer je voudrais néanmoins
vous indiquer une notion de prudence je
crois qu'il faudra conserver tout au
long de l'élaboration que vous serez de
la politique concernant l'instant de la
stratégie de vaccination c'est
premièrement pour l'instant nous ne
disposons que de communiqué de presse de
la part des industriels nous attendons
avec impatience en tant que scientifique
j'attends avec impatience des
publications scientifiques
évidemment il y aura les dossiers qui
seront adressées aux autorités
réglementaires qui sont forcément très
complet ou kiss qui ont déjà été
adressées probablement mais d'où nous
n'avons pas connaissance
deuxièmement par définition le recul à
ce jour sur l'évaluation de la sécurité
et l'efficacité de ces vaccins ne
dépasse pas deux à trois mois donc c'est
encore bref même si c'est très
significatif
troisièmement les données ne sont pas
encore complètes non plus pour savoir
jusqu'à quel point ces vaccins sont
efficaces chez les personnes les plus à
risque donc les personnes âgées et les
personnes souffrant de maladies
chroniques et enfin dernier point qui
est critique mais qui peut dont le la
solution prendra du temps c'est de
savoir si le vaccin d'une part protège
l'individu vaccinés contre l'infection
et espérons le compte d' infections
graves mais aussi protège contre la
transmission
ce qui permettrait de briser la chaîne
de transmission et plus rapidement
arriver à voir la pandémie se résoudre
et il faudra plusieurs mois probablement
pour avoir ce dernier type d'information
qui aussi forcément aura un impact sur
les politiques de vaccination
donc aujourd'hui nous nous avons
informations sur disons pour ce qui
concerne la france de trois vaccins pour
lesquels des essais de phase iii a été
conduit et qui aboutissent sans doute
espérons le à une mise en pratique assez
rapide des premières vaccinations dans
l'ordre chronologique les deux premiers
concernent une stratégie nouvelle de
vaccination qui consiste à injecter ans
par voie intramusculaire ce qu'on
appelle de la rn6 ribonucléique qui est
un message de l'information génétique
qui va qui est enveloppé dans une petite
bulle lipidique toute petite bulle qui
va être capable de pénétrer dans les
cellules en fusionnant avec la membrane
et à l'intérieur des cellules
intramusculaire puisque l'injection et
intramusculaire fait à rennes va
permettre d'être traduit c'est le terme
consacré en sciences en protéines donc
ça sera la protéine dite d' enveloppe la
spike du virus qui est la plus
importante pour obtenu une réponse
immunitaire est donc cette protéine est
en exprimer présente dans les cellules
alain durera une réponse immunitaire
on sait que c'est le cas des études donc
déjà publiés montrent que des anticorps
sont produits de réponse immunitaire
plus larges sont produites donc cette
stratégie est complètement nouvelle
parce qu'elle n'a jamais été utilisé à
grande échelle chez l'homme même s'il ya
eu quelques personnes vaccinées dans le
cas des essais cliniques contre ebola
avec ce type de stratégie donc le
premier c'est celui le vaccin de pfizer
et bayod renntech qui est qui est dans
les premiers résultats étaient propres
annoncée avec une efficacité donc dans
la période de temps que j'ai un ticket
qui dépasse 90% et avec apparemment une
protection également contre les formes
graves de l'infection donc ce sont de
très bonnes nouvelles
ce d'autant qu'il n'a pas été signalé
pour l'instant d'événements indésirables
significatifs au cours des deux à trois
mois qui suivent la vaccination
donc c'est évidemment un espoir
important avec les incertitudes que j'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure les les aspects
logistiques ont été mentionnés je n'y
reviens pas malheureusement ce vaccin a
besoin d'être conservés au froid la rn
est très fragile et donc ce qui
complique la proche logistique mais donc
ce vaccin devrait si les autorisations
de l' agence européenne puis la
l'évaluation française parle hs est
positive pouvoir commencer à être
utilisé pour pour vacciner dans le les
personnes dans les ehpad comme cela a
été indiqué tout à l'heure le deuxième
vaccin qui suit de près et celui la
société moderna qui est fondée sur la
même technologie avec à peu près les
mêmes résultats pour pas être trop long
et donc il va suivre logiquement avec
les possibilités de disposer de ce
vaccin
si encore une fois l'évaluation
règlement
est satisfaisante ensuite il ya une
autre stratégie vaccinale qui repose sur
des petits virus que nous connaissons
bien s'appelle les adénovirus qui sont
des russes banos qui donne les
infections respiratoires des rues mais
en fait ils sont sans gravité
donc on peut modifier ces virus au
laboratoire cela s'est fait déjà depuis
de nombreuses années avec d'autres
objectifs médicaux
cela s'est fait dans le cas de la
vaccination contre ebola avec un certain
succès non ce n'est pas stricto sensu
une technologie tout à fait nouvelle et
donc la société astrazeneca à partir
d'un de prod2 travaux de l'université
d'oxford a développé un tel vaccin et a
fait état de résultats qui indiquent
globalement que sur les personnes
vaccinées environ 10000 comparé aux
groupes contrôlent à peu près un taux de
protection de 70 % royal ya quelques
incertitudes autour de ce vaccin qui
font qu'il sera probalement pas mises en
oeuvre tout de suite non pas
d'apparemment des incertitudes de
sécurité mais l'évaluation d'efficacité
est un tout petit peu biaisé par des
sous groupes
je veux pas entrer dans les détails donc
sans doute ce vaccin sera utilisable si
les valses il est absolument valider en
terme de ces résultats d'efficacité un
côté de la sécurité mais pas tout de
suite et il faut savoir que viendront
plus tard dans l'année en cours en 2021
deux autres types de vaccins qui je
l'espère apportera aussi une
contribution à la politique vaccinale à
la possibilité de vacciner
le troisième est une technologie plus
classique qui consiste à faire produire
par des cellules la protéine d'intérêt
en l'occurrence toujours cette fameuse
protéine spike de l'associer à un
adjuvant lipidique et de l'injecter par
voie intramusculaire
c'est notamment la stratégie choisie fut
une des stratégies choisies par sanofi
mais a également une société américaine
qui est en train de mener des essais de
phase 3 dont on attend des résultats au
printemps et on verra si cette stratégie
est peu aussi complet compléter
l'arsenal de dea et des agents vaccinaux
la 4e stratégie qui viendra encore un
peu plus tard c'est celle qui consiste à
utiliser des virus modifiés capable de
se diviser transitoirement dans le corps
et donc qu'ils amplifient l'expression
de la protéine toujours la même spike
nécessaires à la vaccination c'est
notamment la stratégie qui était
développé par l'institut pasteur avec un
virus de la rougeole atténuer celui qui
est utilisé depuis des dizaines d'années
pour vacciner contre la rougeole donc
avec une très très forte
information sur la sécurité donc il
serait modifié pour permettre
l'expression de la protéine spike il ya
d'autres approches du même type qui sont
développés par l'institut pasteur avec
la société mère donc ces résultats
viendront en cours d'année 2021 et nous
devrions disposer espérons le de tout un
arsenal de vaccin avec des propriétés un
peu différente et qui permettront sans
doute d'adapter les indications en
fonction des caractéristiques des
vaccins notamment sur cette fameuse
question de la protection contre la
transmission un point évidemment crette
que monsieur le premier vous avez déjà
évoqué c'est le fait que il ne faudrait
pas craindre
en tous les cas pas trop craindre que du
fait de l'accélération incroyable de la
recherche de l'innovation industrielle
autour de ces vaccins que les vaccins
soient mises à disposition et que l'on
commence à vacciner des personnes sans
que toutes les mesures de sécurité et
d'évaluation n'est pas été prise donc ça
seul euro les agences réglementaires qui
évalue donc le jean se européenne et les
agences françaises pour ce qui nous
concerne qui évalue la qualité du
produit
ce qu'il n'ya pas d'un kurt et c'est qui
le contiennent qui est vaslui qui évalue
cela sa toxicité éventuelle dans des
injections dans différents types de
modèles animaux il ya toute une
protocole sur ce point qui doit être
strictement respectées qui évalue son
efficacité dans des modèles animaux ce
qui était fait chez des souris chez les
hamsters chez des primates et évidemment
qui évalue les essais cliniques d'abord
dit de phase 1 qui teste la dose
essentiellement les modalités et puis
les essais de phase 3 dont je viens de
parler qui évalue à la fois la sécurité
et l'efficacité et il faut que un vaccin
koch vert si je puis dire pardon sur
chacun de ces items pour qu'ensuite ils
reçoivent une autorisation
il faudrait surtout pas penser que le
fait que le processus se soient
accélérés conduisent à couper les coins
comme on dit en anglais code de cornas
sur sur les conditions de 2,2
d'autorisation de ces vaccins et pour
terminer je voudrais dire un mot
reprendre un point bref qui concerne et
je pense que c'est très important dans
l'établissement une forme de contrat de
confiance entre la population et cette
possibilité de vacciner c'est la
pharmacovigilance donc un certain nombre
d'actions
et évidemment en premier lieu celle de
l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament dans c'est une fonction
des de surveiller de façon très
attentive ce qui se passera chez les
personnes vaccinées pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y ait pas d'événements indésirables
qui seraient éventuellement de faible
fréquence mais même s'ils étaient de
très faible fréquence il faut l'aider
il va falloir les détecter et y répondre
donc cette femme à koji lens va
s'exercer on appelle ça parfois la
vacciner vigilance et aussi en parallèle
sera évalué par par l'inserm notamment
des cordes de sujets vaccinés je crois
que c'est important sur le plan de la
recherche et j'aurai terminé d'un môme
et qui est peut-être le plus important
c'est pour cette vaccination soit
efficace il faut établir la confiance
cette confiance elle peut pas être juste
un message une espèce d'injonction
verticale est maintenant de vous les
autorités de l'état
elle implique à mon avis et c'est
absolument critique et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment travailler sur ces
questions
l'ensemble des acteurs donc encore en
premier lieu les professionnels de santé
qui doivent être eux mêmes convaincus
par une communication transparente et
complète sur les annales analyse
bénéfices/risques comme on dit de ces
vaccins la société civile vous l'avez
dit on peut penser en particulier aux
associations de patients atteints de
maladies chroniques et on a absolument
besoin de l'aide de nos collègues
universitaires et scientifiques des
sciences humaines et sociales qui sont
des spécialistes de l'hésitation
vaccinale sujet qui qui est susceptible
de nous occuper dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent et qui sont si ces
petits d'apporter des propositions sur
la meilleure façon possible de
communiquer est par ailleurs de
faciliter la vaccination sur bercy
merci beaucoup monsieur le professeur
fisher je vais maintenant céder la
parole à la ministre délégué à
l'industrie au secrétaire d'état en
charge des affaires européennes qui vont
comme je lai a lancé vous précisez le
processus d'acquisition des vaccins au
niveau européen
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le premier ministre beaux
jours à tout bon jour à tous comme cela
a été dit en avril dernier sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république la france a formé une
coalition avec l'allemagne avec l'italie
avec les pays bas pour négocier avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
notre enjeu était d'anticiper l'accès au
vaccin pour les 27 états membres et de
sécuriser nos approvisionnements
pour cela nous avons fait le choix
d'utiliser la force du collectif en
négociant au nom de 450 millions
d'européens
nous avons peser davantage face aux
laboratoires que chaque pays pris
individuellement en utilisant la force
du collectif nous avons également éviter
une course contre productive entre pays
et nous avons garanti un vaccin
accessible à tous au même prix et au
même moment y compris au pays dans la
population et moins nombreuses dès le
mois de juin
cette initiative a porté ses fruits avec
la signature d'un premier prêt à corps
elle a été institutionnalisée sous la
forme d'une task force européenne
associant la commission européenne et
six pays dont la france qui ont
directement pris part aux négociations
futures
nous avons retenu une stratégie ciblant
les candidats vaccins sur la base de
trois critères premier critère nous
avons privilégié les vaccins les
candidats vaccins les plus prometteurs
scientifiquement deuxième critère pour
couvrir au plus vite nos besoins nous
avons évidemment cibler les laboratoires
qui étaient les plus avancés dans leurs
études cliniques
troisième critère pour garantir la
sécurité de tous nous avons retenu des
laboratoires qui était prêt à se
soumettre à la procédure d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché en transparence
avec les autorités européennes
tous les candidats vaccins ont été
soumis à un comité scientifique
d'évaluation de seven candidat-vaccin
réunissant des experts venus d'horizons
différents présidée par marie paule
kieny dont la compétence est reconnue
internationalement dans ce cadre nous
avons ciblé plusieurs laboratoires et
plusieurs types de solution vaccinale
ce choix était d'autant plus nécessaire
qu'il s'agissait d' anticiper la
possibilité qu'un ou plusieurs candidats
vaccins voir type de candidat vaccin
puisse connaître un échec
et vous l'avez compris la validation
c'est l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché
c'est ça qui gare à qui indiquent que
nous avons un succès une fois ces
critères scientifiques et médicaux
remplie nous nous sommes employés à
sécuriser industriellement notre
approvisionnement
pour cela nous avons obtenu que la
production des vaccins soient assurés
quasi intégralement sur le sol européen
et notamment en france
nous avons fait en france l'inventaire
de nos capacités de production sur le
territoire national dialoguer avec
l'ensemble des sous-traitants de
l'industrie pharmaceutique pouvant être
mobilisés
notre approche est européenne et les
entreprises présentes en france doivent
pouvoir contribuer à cet objectif de
sécurisation de la production des doses
les deux premiers vaccins pouvant
obtenir une autorisation de mise sur le
marché seront donc en partie fabriqué en
france
c'est le cas de ben tech avec delpharm
sur un site en oeuvre et loire et de
moderna avec récifs armes sur un site en
indre et loire
ce sera aussi le cas du vaccin fabriqué
par sanofi depuis juin comme l'a indiqué
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
donc conclu avec l'union européenne si
contrats de prêts achats de vaccins
correspondant pour la france a un
potentiel de près de 200 millions de
doses ce qui correspond pour l'union
européenne à plus d'un milliard de doses
de nouvelles du négociations ont été
entamées avec d'autres grains candidat
vaccin prometteur la france dans ce
processus a été directement impliqué
dans l'ensemble des négociations et plus
particulièrement chargé de la
négociation de trois contrats sur chaque
contrat la répartition des doses entre
pays européens se fera au prorata de la
population des pays donc 15% des doses
livrées à l'union européenne seront pour
la france cela signifie que pour 100
millions de doses livrées par un
laboratoire 15 millions de doses seront
réservés à la france
comme vous le savez aucun vaccin ne sera
utilisé en france il n'a pas obtenu une
autorisation de mise sur le marché dès
que cette autorisation sera obtenue et
donc nous avons des indications selon
lesquelles des autorisations de mise sur
le marché pourrait être obtenue dans le
courant du mois de décembre
dès que ces autorisations seront obtenus
les entreprises se mettront en ordre de
marche pour livrer simultanément les
doses de vaccins dans chaque pays et
dans des points de livraison qui auront
été convenu avec les autoriser les
autorités sanitaires de chaque pays dans
les semaines qui viennent
nous nous assurerons de la bonne
exécution des contrats et du suivi de la
montée en charge de l'industrialisation
de chacun des vaccins qui ont été mis
sur le marché
merci beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire
d'état en charge des affaires
européennes
merci monsieur le préfet ministre
j'ajouterai simplement quelques mots à
ce que vient de dire la ministre de
l'industrie sur ce cadre européen que
nous avons définies en quelques semaines
à peine et je crois que cela montre
qu'on a été capable de bâtir de manière
très tangible un début d'europe de la
santé qui a fait tant défaut début de
cette pandémie
dans cette réponse nécessaire à la crise
sanitaire
je ne reviens pas sur les chiffres qui
ont été indiquées je veux préciser que
outre la réservation pour l'ensemble des
pays d'un nombre important de dos et un
financement européen qui est également
prévue dans le cadre de cette initiative
commune déjà près de 2 milliards d'euros
sont mobilisés sur le budget européen
pour acquérir les doses de vaccins plus
de 1.5 milliards évoqués par le premier
ministre et par agnès pannier runes
achètent d'autres contrats un septième
notamment plus particulièrement sont en
discussion je vais aussi préciser
puisque une certaine confusion a pu
s'installer qu'il n'y a pas eu davantage
conférer royaume uni à l'occasion du
bric site dans les décisions qu'il a
prises puisqu'il est entièrement soumis
jusqu'au 31 décembre au cadre européen
et qu'il a fait le choix de certaines le
procédure accélérée
nous avons fait le choix du collectif
comme cela a été rappelé de la rapidité
et de la sécurité je crois que ces trois
piliers ensemble que nous devons tenir
pensez au cadre européen et ne pas juger
la situation sur une accélération
délibéré ou sur un seul vaccin mais
comme l'a rappelé le prémunit sur un
ensemble de vaccins qui construisent
notre stratégie je veux dire d'un mot
que au delà de cette stratégie
d'acquisition de vaccins c'est
précisément une robe de la santé qui se
met progressivement et rapidement en
place
nous avons aussi depuis le mois de
septembre harmoniser un certain nombre
de critères sanitaires qui permettent de
définir les zones à risque en europe
nous avons commencé à faire
l'acquisition de matériel commun en
matière de tests d'équipements de
protection et de respirateurs par
exemple certains de ces matériels
d'ailleurs bénéficie d'ores et déjà à la
france dans cette phase de l'épidémie
nous avons organisé en coopération
européenne un certain nombre de gestes
concrets de solidarité dans les deux
sens par exemple le transfert de malades
et puis nous l'avons vu sur les mesures
sanitaires de fin d'année notamment sur
la question sensible par exemple de nos
stations de ski nous activons une
coordination européenne qui commence là
aussi à porter ses fruits mais de nous
devrons aller plus loin à partir de ces
premiers gestes ou de ses premières
initiatives pour bâtir sur ce qui a
marché dans cette initiative vaccinale
particulièrement et c'est le sens de ce
qu'a proposé la commission européenne et
que nous soutenons de construire dans
les mois qui viennent une véritable
agence européenne en matière de santé
qui pourra soutenir des efforts de
recherche accélérée
et puis pour la suite des difficultés
sanitaires éventuels ou pour d'autres
pandémies mieux préparer nos efforts
collectifs et coordonnée au niveau
européen donc que nous avons ici une
stratégie d'europe payante qui nous
protège et qui assure la rapidité la
sécurité et l'efficacité
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant est
enfin passé la parole à notre ministre
des solidarités de la santé olivier
véran pour lui demander un peu d'entrer
dans le détail opérationnel de notre
stratégie vaccinale monsieur misa santé
monsieur premier ministre mais là
monsieur clairement beaucoup de choses
ont déjà été dites peut-être quelques
précisions d'abord c'est vrai que le
vaccin représente un formidable espoir
c'est une prouesse de la science qui
sera à terme les scientifiques
l'ex l'espère une arme qui pourrait être
décisive pour vaincre le virus et
retrouver progressivement une vie
normale pour autant à ce stade nous
devons faire preuve de la plus grande
prudence
d'abord parce que je vais le détail
effectivement il ya encore un certain
nombre d'étapes qui nous faut franchir
avant d'autoriser et distribuer les
vaccins
ensuite parce que au cours des prochains
mois le vaccin ne changera pas
fondamentalement le cours de l'épidémie
il nous faudra donc rester ensemble
vigilant par exemple maintenir les
gestes barrière continuer de se faire
tester procédé au traçage des cas
contacts à la mise à l'abri lorsqu'on
est cas positifs ou qu'à contacter bref
nous resterons pendant certains mois en
prise avec la réalité qui est la nôtre
depuis quelques temps déjà
le premier objectif de la vaccination de
cette vaccination c'est de faire baisser
le nombre des formes graves de kobe 19
les résultats des études cliniques cela
a été dit des candidats vaccins semblent
converger pour démontrer un fai
principale la vaccination permet de
réduire massivement la mortalité due au
virus et à ses formes graves réduire les
formes graves c'est-à-dire réduire la
mortalité mais c'est aussi éviter et le
risque de saturation de nos hôpitaux et
donc aussi laissé du temps et la
possibilité pour le soignant de
s'occuper de toutes les personnes qui
n'ont pas le vide et qui ont tant besoin
de soins dans notre pays je le rappelle
dès à présent trois principes seront
respectés le premier principe c'est le
libre choix des patients le président la
république a été très clair personne ne
sera obligé de se faire vacciner
le deuxième principe c'est la wacc la
gratuité du vaccin parce qu'il ne faut
pas qu'ils les barrières financières
évidemment pour l'accès à la vaccination
est le troisième principe qui pourrait
être aussi le premier c'est la sécurité
puisque la vaccination se fera dans le
strict respect des règles de toutes les
règles qui encadrent l'ensemble de
l'utilisation lusage de l'ensemble des
médicaments des produits de santé dans
notre pays
nous sommes conscients que la question
de la vaccination elle soulève autant de
questions et d'espoir que d'appréhension
pasteur lui-même nous disait ayez le
culte de l'esprit critique
je crois qu'il faut distinguer l'esprit
critique qui avance de l'esprit
suspicieux qui peut trouver toutes les
mauvaises raisons pour ne pas avancer et
qui en définitif et qu'on ne sait plus
on va pasteur toujours lui considéré que
nous devions aux grecs le plus beau mot
de notre langue
le mot selon lui enthousiasme oui il
faut de l' enthousiasme quand on regarde
de près et le progrès et si les
promesses de progrès nous ont parfois
déçus nous ne devons pas renoncer à
cette idée que la science est un
formidable outil d'émancipation une
aventure humaine au service des humains
une chose est sûre c'est que la peur du
vaccin n'arrêtera pas le virus ni celui
ci ni les autres nous nous appuierons
donc sur des agences sanitaires
indépendante dont c'est le métier dans
ce sont les fonctions l'émission dans la
durée pour qu'elles s'assurent que nous
puissions vacciner dans de bonnes
conditions et comme l'a dit le premier
ministre notre rôle c'est de mettre à
disposition le bon vaccin au bon patient
au bon moment
la prudence et l'objectivité doivent
donc que nous guider temps dans le
déploiement dans le déploiement
progressif de la vaccination que dans le
suivi que nous organiserons
parallèlement à la mise en place de ces
garanties essentielles nous avons déjà
préparé ce qu'on appelle la stratégie
vaccinale c'est à dire la définition des
personnes prioritaires dans la
vaccination est le calendrier pour le
dire autrement nous faisons en sorte que
les premières doses de vaccin bénéficie
à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
cette stratégie vaccinale est déployé
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle cette
fois ci la campagne de vaccination la
campagne vaccinale c'est la manière dont
on va s'organiser pour distribuer
administrer les doses de vaccin pour
permettre l'accès à ce vaccin sur tout
le territoire dans des bonnes conditions
de sécurité et je le disais tout à
l'heure au bon moment
comment et par qui est défini cette
stratégie de vaccination en france vous
avez entendu parler de la haute autorité
de santé
la has qui est une autorité indépendante
qui a remis des premières
recommandations notamment sur les
publics prioritaires et qui constituent
le fondement de notre feuille de route
pour les prochaines semaines
ce que nous dit la hsc que le premier
objectif de la vaccination doit être et
c'est logique de protéger en priorité
les personnes qui ont des formes graves
de la maladie ou qui peuvent ans décédé
les personnes en vend de priorité 1
relève ainsi de deux catégories d'abord
les personnes âgées
séjournant en établissements collectifs
notamment les ehpad les maisons de
retraite
vous allez me dire pourquoi est ce que
une personne âgée de 80 ans serait plus
facilement vacciner en premier temps si
elle vit en ehpad que si elle vit à la
maison
et bien ce que nous dit également la hsc
que la vie en collectivité exposé aux
risques de virus puisque on le sait nous
l'avons vu au cours des deux vagues
épidémiques lorsque le virus rentrer
dans une maison de retraite rentrer dans
un ehpad
hélas la plupart du temps il ne va pas
faire qu'un malade il va en faire
plusieurs et cela pourrait conduire à de
nombreux décès c'est pour cela que la
haute autorité de santé recommande de
les prioriser deuxième public
prioritaire les personnels de santé de
ces établissements en contact avec les
personnes âgées
lorsque même présente une vulnérabilité
ou liées à leur âge ou liées à leur état
de santé avec ce qu'on appelle des
comorbidités c'est à dire des maladies
qui les expose à des risques de forme
grave
par la suite cette cible sera élargie
progressivement d'abord aux personnes
âgées de plus de 75 ans + puis de plus
de 65 ans puis aux professionnels des
secteurs de la santé ou du secteur
médico social
âgé de 50 ans et plus et présentant des
comorbidités au delà de cette deuxième
étape la cible vaccinale sera
progressivement élargi en suivant les
indications de la has nous allons donc
avoir une vaccination progressive en
trois étapes qui apparaît sur la
vignette et la diapositive à compter de
début janvier 2021 on l'espère moment
auquel nous devrions disposer des
premiers vaccins autorisés est livrée si
tout se passe bien dans un nombre encore
limité de dos l'a été dit nous
proposerons donc la vaccination aux
personnes âgées hébergées en
établissement notamment évidemment dans
les ehpad
mais également aux professionnels de
santé à risque exerçant dans ces
établissements
ça correspond à environ un million de
personnes
au delà de leur vulnérabilité au virus
ce sont des personnes qui en plus ont
besoin et on le sait de retrouver du
lien familial du lien social de
bénéficier à nouveau de visites
régulières de leurs proches qui suit
comme brigitte bourguignon qui ministre
délégué en charge de l'autonomie
particulièrement sensible cette campagne
sera spécifique dans son organisation et
son parcours j'y reviendrai parce
qu'elle se déroule en établissement et
avec un vaccin le fameux weiser by one
tech qui se conserve dans des conditions
très spécifiques de température vous
l'avez entendu moins 80 degrés entre
février et mars 2021 selon le calendrier
effectif des autorisations de mise sur
le marché et de livraison des vaccins
suivant c'est à dire le mot derna et le
astrazeneca notamment nous pourrons
passer à la vaccination des publics
prioritaires suivants toujours défini
par la haute autorité de santé
c'est à dire je le disais les personnes
âgées de 75 ans et plus puis les
personnes âgées de 65 ans et plus les
professionnels de santé et
médico-sociaux âgées de 50 ans et ou
vulnérables de par leur co morbidités
cette fois ci on parle quand même de 14
millions de français
enfin dès que cette deuxième phase sera
achevée
nous entamons alors la troisième phase
de la campagne vaccinale cette fois ci
ce qu'on appelle la campagne grand
public
en élargissant encore le public visé ce
sera le temps de la vaccination si je
puis dire de masse avec cette fois ci
seront concernés les personnes âgées de
50 à 64 ans les professionnels des
secteurs essentiels au fonctionnement du
pays en période épidémique
vous l'imaginez personnel de sécurité
d'éducation qui travaillent dans
l'alimentation les personnes vulnérables
et précaires et les professionnels qui
les prennent en charge les personnes qui
vivent dans des hébergements confiné où
des lieux clos et enfin le reste de la
population majeure dès la première étape
et plus encore lors de la vaccination
grand public
nous mettrons l'accent sur ceux qui sont
au coeur de toute campagne de
vaccination et qui sont les mêmes les
plus à même d'avoir une relation de
confiance avec les français
vous avez compris je vais évidemment
parler des professionnels de santé et en
premier lieu des médecins et en premier
lieu des médecins généralistes nous
allons nous appuyer fortement sur les
médecins de notre pays
je le répète à ce stade compte tenu des
incertitudes qui entourent le calendrier
des autorisations les dates peuvent être
amenés à bouger
ce sont les références que nous nous
donnons pour nous organiser et ne pas
perdre de temps le moment venu nous
sommes entrés dans la phase de
l'organisation et de la planification de
la première étape vaccinale je le dis
cela constitue un défi logistique
immense au delà de ce que notre pays a
pu connaître par le passé
le vaccin pfizer by one tech qui
arrivera en premier et sera donc
destinée aux établissements pour
personnes âgées mais également les
personnes âgées en situation de handicap
dans des hébergements collectifs sous la
houlette de sophie cluzel secrétaire
d'état en charge présente des
caractéristiques particulières puisqu'il
doit être stocké à moins 80 degrés je le
disais et une fois décongelés il nous
faut pouvoir d'administrer aux patients
en moins de cinq jours
c'est avec ces contraintes qu'il va nous
falloir viser une livraison de plus de
dix mille établissements collectifs
d'hébergement de personnes âgées
tout cela rend nécessaire d'avoir une
organisation bien huilée bien
spécifiques par exemple des supers
congélateur genou nous en avons déjà
commandé j'en ai déjà parlé mais
également vous l'imaginez des seringue
des aiguilles du matériel de protection
des moyens de transport et des moyens
logistiques spécifiques et vu ses
conditions de conservation il y aura par
ailleurs deux circuits complémentaires
pour plus de sécurité un circuit
principal de distribution qui va
s'appuyer sur les acteurs qui ont
l'habitude d'acheminer des médicaments
même dans des conditions difficiles et
notamment les vaccins ce circuit sera
destiné aux ehpad un second circuit
s'appuiera lui sur une centaine
d'établissements hospitaliers bien
répartis sur tout le territoire national
évidemment dans les territoires
ultramarins et qui visera cette fois ci
a appris à approvisionner les
établissements hébergeant des personnes
âgées qui sont directement en lien avec
ces hôpitaux dans la deuxième moitié du
mois de décembre
ce circuit logistique sera testé à blanc
et prouver à travers des opérations qui
seront conduites
quelques mots sur le parcours patient
les personnes prioritaires se verront
proposer en amont de la vaccination
une consultation médicale il s'agira de
vérifier l'état de santé de la personne
d'éventuelles contre indications à la
vaccination
il s'agira d'informer la personne sur
les bénéfices risques du vaccin pourquoi
est ce qu'on lui propose ce vaccin est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on lui proposant ces
conditions et puis recueillir son
consentement pour la vaccination
cette consultation médicale pourra dans
certains cas d'ailleurs donné lieu tout
de suite à la vaccination lorsque c'est
envisageable
s'agissant des résidents en ehpad
évidemment les familles seront associés
étroitement à cette procédure médicale
d'autant plus d'ailleurs si les
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie ne
sont pas capables de donner leur
consentement dans les meilleures
conditions
précision utile le vaccin fader by one
tech nécessite deux injections qui
doivent être réalisés à 21 jours d'écart
avec une petite marge de 2 3 jours donc
il faut en même temps qu'on réalise la
première injection déjà prévoir la
seconde injection de ce vaccin
et puis en aval de la vaccination mais
vous l'imaginez bien un suivi sanitaire
un suivi médical sera garantie assurée
pour les personnes qui auront été
vaccinés nous disposons pour cela de
tous les circuits de veille sanitaire de
vigilance qui recueille les effets
indésirables qu'ils soient bénins moyens
sévère et tout cela évidemment nous
permettra d'avoir ce suivi en population
réelle
pour résumer si je suis résidents en
ehpad un médecin va venir me voir ou
peut-être en téléconsultation vérifiera
mon état de santé ne proposera le cas
échéant d'être vacciné recueillir à mon
consentement après s'être assurée que
j'ai tout compris
une fois que j'aurai consenti je serai
vacciner une première fois j'aurai un
rappel au bout de trois semaines et
ensuite un suivi médical sera garantie
dans la durée pour vérifier que tout se
passe bien comme je vous le disais au
début de ma prise de parole les
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé seront actualisées en fonction des
données recueillies au fil de l'eau
s'agissant de chaque vaccin ainsi que de
leur disponibilité effective et des
tensions éventuelles sur
l'approvisionnement
c'est un point majeur
ce stade je le disais les résultats des
études cliniques et des candidats
vaccins semblent converger pour montrer
que la vaccination permet de réduire
massivement la mortalité due au virus et
à ses formes graves si les données futur
nous montrait que certains vaccins en
plus un impact significatif sur la
transmission du virus lui même
ça permettrait de réorienter notre
stratégie nous passerions d'une
stratégie centrée sur la réduction des
formes graves à une stratégie de
contrôle de l'épidémie en population
générale
nous ajusterons donc notre approche au
fur et à mesure de la progression de nos
connaissances pour finir évidemment je
veillerai informés et associés
directement les directeurs des ehpad
avec brigitte bourguignon
les professionnels de santé en ville à
l'hôpital les résidents des
établissements pour que l'information
soit claire transparente
actualisé en temps réel d'ores et déjà
plus de 40 réunions se sont tenues au
point de mon ministère
demain je réunir l ensemble des
représentants des professions de santé
pour diffuser un maximum d'informations
en temps réel où gilles bourguignon fera
de même avec le secteur médico-social
lundi pour finir j'apporterai une grande
attention à la communication vis-à-vis
des collectivités territoriales le
premier ministre l'a dit nous sommes en
lien étroit avec des représentants des
communes des départements des régions
pour les associer à toutes les étapes et
toutes les modalités pratiques de
l'organisation de la campagne vaccinale
pour conclure vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
avant même de nous immuniser contre le
coronavirus nous devons d'abord nous
immuniser contre les peurs et c'est
aussi ma responsabilité
notre responsabilité collective le
vaccin contre la peur c'est la
connaissance et c'est la bonne
compréhension et je m'engage tout au
long de la campagne vaccinale à ce que
nous fassions preuve de la transparence
la plus totale sur l'efficacité du
vaccin
l'acceptabilité par la population
l'évolution des recommandations
scientifiques et médicales
l'organisation pratique de la campagne
les éventuels effets indésirables qu'ils
soient graves ou bénin nous porterons
une attention de chaque instant à ce que
vous disposiez du même niveau
d'information que nous la vaccination a
fait reculer de nombreuses épidémies
dans le monde l'a d'ailleurs permis
professeur d'éradiquer certaines
maladies qui ont disparu aujourd'hui
comme la variole qui pourtant avait
ravagé des territoires entiers de la
planète pendant des décennies et des
siècles
le vaccin est donc une chance que nous
devons saisir que nous devons saisir
dans les bonnes conditions et que nous
devons saisir avec vous merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
mesdames et messieurs vous l'avez
compris cette campagne de vaccination va
très fortement mobilisé l'ensemble du
gouvernement dans les prochaines
semaines elle sera pilotée sous ma
responsabilité par le ministre chargé de
la santé olivier véran en lien
évidemment avec l'ensemble des
ministères concernés auprès du ministre
des solidarités de la santé sera créé un
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale chargé d'appuyer le
gouvernement dans les choix qu'il sera
conduit à faire en la matière ce concert
comprendra des représentants des
différentes parties prenantes que le
gouvernement entend associer à la mise
en oeuvre de cette politique vaccinale
des experts scientifiques y compris des
sciences humaines et sociales des
professionnels de santé des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales des associations de
patients et des citoyens eux mêmes au
travers du cadre de dialogue mis en
place par le conseil économique social
et environnemental
j'ai demandé au professeur alain fischer
de présider ce conseil d'orientation et
je le remercie vivement d'avoir accepté
mes chers concitoyens l'arrivée du
vaccin est un vrai motif d'espoir une
nouvelle étape qui fera appel à nouveau
à notre sens des responsabilités et de
la solidarité comme le président de la
république l'a annoncé
la vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
c'est le choix de la confiance mais il
faut que nous soyons les plus nombreux
possibles à nous faire vacciner car se
faire vacciner c'est se protéger face à
un virus dont nous connaissons
maintenant la dangerosité et la
contagiosité
se faire vacciner c'est aussi protéger
les autres c'est un acte altruiste et ce
n'est qu'au terme d'un effort collectif
important que nous pourrons atteindre un
niveau de protection immunitaire
suffisant pour retrouver une vie sociale
économique éducative culturelle sportive
normal une nouvelle étape va donc
s'ouvrir mais qui ne marquera pas la fin
de l'épidémie
la campagne de vaccination qui est sur
le point de commencer va s'étaler on
vous l'a dit sur plusieurs mois
ce sera donc une arme nouvelle qui va
s'ajouter à nos autres outils mais qui
ne saurait les remplacer le respect des
mesures de prudence et des gestes
barrières bien sûr mais aussi la
stratégie tester alerté protéger cette
stratégie qui reste au coeur de notre
action au long cours contre l'épidémie
et qui va connaître dans les prochaines
semaines des évolutions importantes
notamment avec l'accélération du
déploiement des tests dits antigénique
l'expérimentation de dépistage de masse
dans trois villes françaises
l'enrichissement des fonctions de
l'application tous antico vide et enfin
le renforcement du dispositif
d'accompagnement en isolement des
personnes malades ou qu'à contacter
sur tous ces points nous reviendrons de
manière détaillée lors de la prochaine
conférence de presse la semaine
prochaine après avoir préalablement
consulté les groupes parlementaires dans
le cadre du comité de liaison que je
vient d'instituer avec l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat afin de renforcer
la fluidité des relations entre le
parlement et le gouvernement sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
je vous remercie et je me tiens avec des
ministres à votre disposition mesdames
et messieurs pour répondre à vos
questions
bonsoir marie casadebaig journaliste
donc rfi radio france internationale
tout à l'heure le professeur fisher
disait qu'on ne savait pas encore si
les candidats vaccins protégées contre
l'infection et la transmission du coffee
de 19
je voulais donc savoir finalement quel
était leur efficacité sur quoi il
s'agissait pour les rendre brengues le
virus moins dangereux très bien monsieur
le premier ministre messieurs les
ministres le ministre monsieur le
professeur plusieurs questions
concernant cette stratégie vaccinale
tout d'abord quelle part de la
population devra être vaccinée pour que
cette vaccination soit efficace y at il
des contre indications à se faire
vacciner si nous avons déjà était
infectée par la copie de 19 à vous des
données scientifiques à ce sujet comptez
vous vacciner les plus jeunes les
mineurs vous n'en avez pas fait état
lors de cette conférence de presse pour
l'instant et dernière question
concernant les contrats que vous êtes
passé existe il une qu une clause qui
indique que s'il ya des effets néfastes
ou nocifs les états s'engagent à ne pas
aller devant la justice contre ces
laboratoires est ce que ces contrats
prévoient par exemple également des
indemnisations dans certaines conditions
pour les fabricants concernant les
risques encourus
merci merci d'un prix monsieur bonsoir
camille caudin une question sur les le
rôle des médecins généralistes vous
insister là dessus est ce qu'il y aura à
ce que les pharmaciens aussi auront un
rôle dans le processus de vaccination et
comment à partir de quelle phase ils
pourront tenir ce rôle
et comment concrètement cela peut
s'organiser dans des cabinets ou des
dans des pharmacies
lorsqu'on parle de vaccins de fioles de
vaccins qui permettent de vacciner
plusieurs personnes en même temps sur
une même fioles on a du mal à imaginer
concrètement comment cela s'organise et
puis deuxième question vous disais qu'il
fallait continuer à tenir tous ses
gestes barrières même s'il y a des
vaccins est-ce qu'il est envisagé quand
même de desserrer l'étau sur le port du
masque notamment dehors tout en laissant
en intérieur desserrer l'étau
progressivement merci beaucoup
enfin prime abord
est ce que pascal morel monsieur le
premier ministre sur les médecins
pharmaciens comme olivier verront le
ministre de la santé l'a précisé et les
infirmières interviendront il uniquement
dans la 3e phase où dès le début de
cette campagne de vaccination comment
allez-vous deuxième question organisé
cette logistique de manière précise ça
paraît évidemment tout à fait
considérable ce que vous aurez est ce
que vous faites appel à des fournisseurs
particulier comment allez vous vous
organiser et la troisième question c'est
s'il y a de nouveau virus plus promet
deux nouveaux vaccins pardon plus
prometteurs la merci des vaccins je me
ressaisis tout le monde sera derrière si
les deux s'il y avait de nouveaux
vaccins plus prometteur est ce que vous
adapterez votre stratégie d'achat parce
qu'évidemment vous dites que vous en
acheter 200 millions mais s'il s'avérait
que ces vaccins qu'il y avait des
vaccins plus prometteur est ce que vous
modifierez votre stratégie d'achat merci
on va va s'arrêter là s'il vous plaît je
on y reviendra mais il faut qu'on
répondre à ces questions alors peut-être
ben c'est surtout des questions
sanitaires s'agissant d'une stratégie
vaccinale c'est peut être un j'en ai
quand même peut-être en va d'abord juste
traiter les deux questions qui
concernent la politique d'achat la toute
dernière
et puis celle sur les stipulations
contractuelles par rapport à des effets
nocifs les relâche avec les laboratoires
alors parce que c'est plutôt agnès qui
va venir répondre donc sur la question
de la politique d'achats d'abord c'est
une pré-réservation de doses ça veut
dire que s'il n'y a pas d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché il n'ya pas
d'achat c'est assez tautologique mais
c'est ça va mieux en le rappelant la
deuxième chose c'est qu'évidemment et
c'est ce que nous faisons au fil de
l'eau à chaque fois que nous avons des
candidats vaccins qui se présentent ils
sont présentés d'ailleurs en fait ils
sont régulièrement représentés au comité
qui nous accompagnent et qui est
présidée par marie paule kieny mais
auquel le professeur fisher fait
également don
le professeur fisher fait également
partie pour nous indiquer celui là il
est recommandé celui là il ya eu de
celui là on est moins enthousiaste
donc ça nous permet d'ajuster à chaque
moment est de présenter ces avis il faut
d'ailleurs savoir que les avis du comité
français sont diffusées au niveau de la
commission européenne est très apprécié
et guident notre stratégie collective et
donc c'est comme ça que nous avons
entamé de nouvelles discussions avec des
candidats vaccins assez prometteur dans
les phases 1
mais on est encore en phase 1 sur la
question de l'indemnisation alors ya une
loi
il ya même une directive européenne qui
a été retracée 8 en français dans la loi
française et qui est très clair c'est
que le producteur est responsable du
dommage causé par un défaut de son
produit qu'ils soient ou non liés par un
contrat avec la victime et les clauses
qui viserait à écarter 70 les
responsables limitation à limiter la
responsabilité du fait des produits
défectueux sont interdites est réputée
non écrite
donc de ce point de vue là quelle que
soit la manière dont on voudrait
imaginer de rédiger des contrats
responsabilité des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
et effectivement encadré ensuite comme
nous l'avons fait sur d'autres
je dirais situation nous avons créé en
france l'oniam qui est un organisme qui
vise un désign indemniser des patients
qui auraient eu difficulté un dommage
médical dont la responsabilité n'est pas
imputable au laboratoire est évidemment
dans ce cas comme dans d'autres cas
l'oniam pourra venir en appui des
patients français de la question sur
l'espace il ya des nouveaux vaccins
capart fc ça en cours de route par
rapport à ce qui serait plus efficace
que ce que nous aurions précommander
bien sa passion elle est donc là alors
ça c'est plutôt une adaptation de la
stratégie vaccinale
c'est à moitié
achat à moitié stratégie vaccinale comme
vous l'avez compris comme il ya
plusieurs phases et une montée en
puissance et au fur et à mesure de la
disponibilité des données n'a dans la
stratégie d'achats interrogés je rentre
un peu dans le détail mais demandé aux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques de nous
communiquer aussi des données
spécifiques sur les personnes âgées sur
tel type de pathologie pour faire des
sous groupes y avoir une connaissance
très profonde de ce que l'on peut faire
on a également d'ailleurs avec le
ministère de la recherche
regardez si on pouvait pas complété par
des études académiques qui permettent
d'avoir une très bonne connaissance sur
des sous groupes déterminés de l'impact
des vaccins évidemment il appartiendra
la haute autorité de santé d'adapter les
stratégies vaccinales en fonction des
populations et sur la base des résultats
de phase iii est quelque chose
d'important rappelé que les résultats de
phase iii
c'est des dizaines de milliers de
patients donc c'est des données
statistiquement très intéressant merci
alors il ya plusieurs questions là pour
le le ministre est peut-être le
professeur fisher un des questions très
précises très techniques que vous avez
noté à la fois sur l'efficacité les
enfants les contre indications et c'est
l'intervention des pharmaciens le port
du masque
gg noter aussi monsieur prix ministre
les questions fusent j'espère les avoir
tout noté d'abord sur la question du
vaccin et des gestes barrières je
comprends la question c'est finalement
si on commence à vacciner pourquoi est
ce qu on libérerait pas la contrainte
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on garderait le
masque à l'extérieur pourquoi est-ce que
alors plusieurs réponses à cela
oui on va garder le masque oui on va
garder les gestes barrières et ce
pendant plusieurs mois je le disais tout
à l'heure
pourquoi d'abord parce que la
vaccination sera progressive
elle va prendre plusieurs mois de
nombreux mois pour pouvoir couvrir
progressivement la population donc
pendant toute une période de temps il ya
des personnes qui seront vaccinés et des
personnes qui ne seront pas ensuite nous
savons que le vaccin dont nous avons à
connaître l'efficacité aujourd'hui
d'après les études cliniques et de ce
que nous disent les autorités
scientifiques indépendantes c'est que il
est efficace sur les formes graves en
tout cas ça évite d'avoir des formes
graves de la maladie ce qui ne nous
garantit pas que il évite la
transmission du virus
donc je à ce stade nous n'avons pas
suffisamment d'informations et c'est un
usage que nous le serons a été dit aussi
par le professeur fisher tout à l'heure
donc potentiellement je peux être
vaccinés être protégés de faire une
forme grave mais rien n'indique que je
ne puisse pas contaminer quelqu'un
d'autre on le sera progressivement et
puis donc on continue comme ça pour
l'instant avec les mesures de protection
collective
ensuite plusieurs questions sur qui
vaccinent qui vaccineront l'a dit et
c'est fondamental dans une campagne de
vaccination comme celle ci le médecin
doit être au coeur du dispositif
une consultation auprès vaccinale un
suivi médicalisé tout au long et donc
les médecins vont s'assurer de la
vaccination des personnes âgées en ehpad
un établissement collectif des personnes
handicapés en établissements collectifs
et c'est en toute l'étape
ensuite il y aura une possible extension
nous verrons quelles sont les vaccins
qui sont disponibles si nous devons
utiliser le vaccin de pfizer by one tech
qui se conservent moins 80 degrés pour
commencer à vacciner entre guillemets en
ville
il est probable je vais des guillemets
que nous privilégierons les endroits
type maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires centre de santé où
plusieurs médecins à plusieurs
professionnels de santé sont rassemblés
permettant d'avoir un flux de patients
justifiant de vacciner dans ces cités
puis l'extension vers la médecine de
ville se fera de plus en plus forte à
mesure que les nouveaux vaccins
arriveront et que les publics grandiront
de personnes qui sont vaccinées
la question se posera de savoir est ce
qu on en reste aux seuls médecins dans
la vaccination ou est-ce qu'on peut
associer d'autres professionnels de
santé pour le geste vaccinal comme des
pharmaciens je n'ai pas la réponse à
cette question qui est tout à fait
légitime
la haute autorité de santé sera chargé
comme elle le fait pour toutes les
campagnes de vaccination de formuler des
recommandations que nous suivrons là
aussi scrupuleusement
est-ce que les trois une question qui
est troisième salve de questions sur les
populations à vacciner est ce qu'on
vaccine que les personnes majeures où
les mineurs j'ai bien précisé qu'à ce
stade des recommandations dont nous
disposons s'arrête aux personnes
majeures
peut-être que les recommandations
évoluera peut-être qu'elle n'évolueront
pas ça dépendra des données qui seront
renvoyés par les différents laboratoires
et donc à ce stade de toute façon pour
les prochains mois si vous avez bien
suivi le long cheminement de la
stratégie vaccinale
vous savez qu on est loin d'un public
mineur on est sur un public pour
l'instant âgées fragiles et
progressivement on ira vers des pubs les
publics majeurs sans fragilité
particulière sur le d autres questions
vous avez pu poser je crois qu'on a oui
est ce qu'il ya eu dans les camps en
train de noyer sur en ligue at-il voilà
y at il déjà des patients qui auraient
ulcos vides et qu'il faudra vacciner
ce qu'on sait sous couvert d'une
professeur fisher c'est que dans les
études qui ont été faites de phase iii
sur les quarante mille patients
quarante-et-une personnes aux états unis
il y avait des gens qui ont été vaccinés
qu'il y avait déjà eu un vide de sorte
qu'on sait dans le pré les études qui
ont été qui sont analysées par les
autorités de santé les personnes qui ont
déjà été vaccinées qui ont été vaccinées
alors qu'elle avait une copine n'ont pas
fait de réaction particulière donc ça ça
doit répondre
j'imagine à votre question et puis et
puis avec quel parent dans la population
en faudrait-il atteindre pour que
finalement ces opérations vaccinale soit
efficace global c'est la suite logique
de notre première question est de la
même manière que je vous ai dit qu'à ce
stade on ne sait pas encore garantir
qu'être vacciner et protège les autres
on sait que ça se protège on se protège
toi même pour l'instant ce stade si ça
arrive si la vaccination protège et en
plus les autres c'est à dire si ça
m'évitait de transmettre le virus à
d'autres personnes
alors là on pourrait commencer
la d'immunisation de la population voire
d' immunité collective et ensuite se
poser la question de quel est le
pourcentage de population à vacciner
habituellement professeur je crois qu'on
parle de 60 % d'une population qui doit
être protégés par la vaccination ou par
une immunisation lié au fait qu'on a
déjà été malade avec le corona virus on
peut penser que c'est la même chose on
peut aussi être vigilant puisque le
coronavirus ne ressemble pas à tous les
virus ça nous aurait pas échappé qu'on a
pu connaître ces dernières années vous
avez monsieur fisher quelques précisions
apportées a tout dit bon il est là si
vous voulez le voir après alors on prend
d'autres questions bonjour je la mi-mars
au delà fp2 question pour les services
de la fp la première comment votre
campagne vaccinale va-t-elle se déployer
dans les déserts médicaux
est-ce qu'il va il faudra avoir des se
déplacer et dans quelle mesure voilà
vous mettre en place d accompagnement
spécifique pour ces zones la deuxième
question qui rejoint celle de mon
confrère sur les approvisionnements ont
observé des tensions d'approvisionnement
pour le vaccin contre la grippe
comment allez-vous vous assurer que les
pharmacies ou les médecins seront
effectivement approvisionné pour
promener cette campagne je vous en prie
madame bonjour monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez évoqué plusieurs fois
pendant cette conférence de presse les
fêtes de fin d'année le fait de ne pas
relâcher nos efforts
je vous cite je me permets donc de
m'écarter très légèrement du sujet des
vaccins et des bouquets n'y a pas de
problème c'est bien et d'évoquer la
fermeture donc des domaines skiables
cette forte colère qui est en train de
monter de la part notamment des
professionnels du ski et des élus
ma question est est ce que vous entendez
cette colère est est ce que vous seriez
prêt à revenir sur votre décision de
fermer les domaines skiables pendant
noël merci à bien merci bonsoir monsieur
le premier ministre à un ministre
professeur jacques sereys journaliste à
rtl vous l'avez dit la vaccination ne
sera pas obligatoire est ce que cela
vaut aussi pour le personnel des ehpad
et une seconde question présentez-vous
officiellement le professeur fisher
comme le monsieur vaccin du gouvernement
et si oui pourquoi n'est ce pas monsieur
louis charles viossat qui avait été un
temps pressenti pour cette fonction
merci bonsoir
laureline du bio au journal la croix de
question pour moi d'abord est ce que
vous pourriez détaillé s'il vous plaît
le calendrier du conseil citoyen et la
deuxième serait de savoir si l'armée
viendra en appui logistique du coût de
ces sociétés privées dont on vous
parlait merci bien on va répondre
peut-être à ce jeu de la question donc
le évidemment le sont pour la plupart
sanitaire ça je réponds tu comme ça vous
ça vous fait préparer à deux qui me
semble être plus directement adressé
celle d'abord sur le conseil citoyen qui
a été évoquée donc comme je voulais
indiqué et contenus de de ses
prérogatives
nous avons un accord avec lui bien
entendu pris la tâche du président du
conseil économique et social
environnemental et donc nous sommes en
train c'est pas abouti encore exactement
mais nous sommes en train de bâtir avec
lui les la procédure par laquelle ce
conseil citoyen de cette association des
citoyens à la au déploiement de la
stratégie vaccinale va être organisée
donc ma réponse est en cours réponse
dans quelques jours avec le conseil
économique et social environnemental
alors s'agissant de la fermeture des
domaines skiables
vous avez parlé delà de la colère des
professionnels bien entendu je les ai
vus comme un dieu je la connais je les
comprends je les ai reçus deux fois mon
niveau il ya des discussions qui se
poursuivent sous l'égide à la fois
de jean-baptiste lemoyne et de bruno le
maire j'ai moi même vous le savez je
leur ai fixé une nouvelle clause de
rendez vous le 11 décembre
je voudrais à nouveau réexpliqué ma
position qui n'a pas évolué puisque
c'était votre question effectivement à
ce que nous souhaitons éviter par dessus
tout cours de cette période des fêtes
c'est les grands mouvements de
population les rassemblements dans des
dans des lieux déterminés alors c'est
pas tellement les activités à
l'extérieur évidemment dans ces stations
qui nous gêne mais plus les
rassemblements à l'intérieur et les
regroupements qui peuvent avoir lieu le
soir ou la journée peu importe donc
c'est une mesure préventive qui nous a
conduit à prendre cette décision
rappelant qu actuellement sous
l'autorité du ministère de la santé
nous voyons quelles activités peuvent
être malgré tout maintenu et sous la
conduite du ministre chargé de
l'économie
nous travaillons aux indemnisations pour
les professionnels et les équipements de
cette des activités qui ne pourront pas
être maintenue donc voilà c'est encore
une fois je me rappelle à tous je le
redis quand on veut éviter la
propagation de l'épidémie et qu'on doit
prendre des mesures dites de freinage
parce que cette propagation est forte
il nous faut prendre des mesures
préventives quel que soit à la limite la
qualité des protocoles sanitaires qui
encadre les lieux où les activités
concernées pour éviter encore une fois
la source les déplacements les récemment
population rappelle on a quelques
chiffres dans les stations se sont
inscrits normal la population sur un
lieu déterminé peut aller peut être
utilisé jusqu'à 7,8
bon donc on voit bien que là il ya un
risque spécifique et j'observe
d'ailleurs je vous avais informe même si
c'était pas tout à fait votre question
puisque parmi les motifs de colère que
j'entends encore une fois que je
comprends parfaitement je me permets de
rappeler que
je suis moi même un élu de la montagne
il y à celle que les pays voisins eux ne
prendrai pas les mêmes mesures que nous
je comprends surtout lorsque les pays en
question sont limitrophes des stations
françaises concerne uniquement
et lorsque je peux vous dire c'est que
évidemment nous nous souhaitons nous
puisque c'est la sécurité sanitaire qui
motive de décision que surtout à
situation sanitaire comparable et comme
je les dis il ya même des pays beaucoup
quand une situation sanitaire plus
dégradée que la nôtre que des mesures
comparables soit prise ou en tout cas
protectrice donc nous avons clément
bonne pour à le compléter engager une
action diplomatique et européennes et je
vois que les choses progressent
jour après jour puisque après pour faire
simple que l'allemagne notamment la
bavière et l'italie est également adopté
le même raisonnement que nous je pense
ce soir et sous réserve de confirmation
prochaine que l'andorre également a
décidé de décaler à début janvier
l'ouverture de ces stations de ski quant
à l'espagne si j'ai bien compris
au cours d'une réunion qui a eu lieu
aujourd'hui même entre gouvernement
espagnol et les communautés autonomes
parce que vous savez que dans beaucoup
de ces pays la décision n'appartient pas
au gouvernement central il aurait été il
a été décidé que pour celles des régions
et communautés autonomes
je pense à catalogne je pense à l'aragon
qui rouvrira leur station là aussi pour
limiter les flux il est temps limiteront
l'accès aux résidents de ces communautés
autonomes donc ce qui règle si je puis
dire le problème par rapport à nos
concitoyens qui pourrait être désireux
de s'y rendre
l'autriche qui pourtant à une économie
fortement basée sur neige a également
pris des mesures très restrictives
allant dans le même sens et nous
attendons la position des autorités
helvétiques où là aussi vous savez que
ça dépend des cantons ce qui est très
intéressant
mesdames et messieurs c'est que cette
évolution qui va dans le sens d'une
harmonisation n'est pas simplement due
à l'action diplomatique de la france
dont je salue la qualité bien entendu
mais elle est surtout dû j'ai moi même
appelé beaucoup de mes homologues à leur
conscience comme la nôtre qui
effectivement compte tenu de la
situation épidémique et des risques qui
s'attachait à ses activités
eh bien il fallait faire de la
prévention est limité au maximum au
maximum les risques sanitaires
dernier élément je voulais dit je
recevrai les stations de ski le le
contact n'est pas absolument pas rompues
ce que les élus les professionnels
je pense qu'il faut déjà et c'est assez
logique préparer plus tôt la phase
suivante je pense de mémoire que c'est
autour de 20% ou 18 % le chiffre
d'affaires qu'elles font à noël
l'essentiel est au contraire janvier
février mars et lui avec joie là il faut
que je pense être assez logique cohérent
pour nous
si à nouveau à l'occasion des fêtes de
fin d'année il y à des pratiques qui
favorisent le redémarrage économie alors
c'est au moment où ces stations
réaliseront le plein de leurs activités
que nous devrions les fermer si les
chiffres sont à nouveau mauvaise ce qui
évidemment je ne souhaite ni n'espère
donc je suis comment dire dans la
fonction qui est la mienne mais depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis plusieurs mois
obligé de prendre des mesures difficiles
qu'ils génèrent pour reprendre votre
terme la colère que je comprends
l'honneur du gouvernement français c'est
d'écouter cette colère c'est
d'indemniser ceux qui sont les victimes
de ces décisions à caractère sanitaire
parce qu'il n'est pas question de
l'heure à faire payer le prix m il est
aussi madame demande de voir de mon
devoir de veiller par dessus tout et
avant tout à la sécurité de mes
concitoyens ce que j'essaie de faire de
manière constante
alors j'appelle maintenant le ministre
de la santé pour les autres questions
sur les déserts médicaux les
approvisionnements etc
j'ai vu quatre questions je vais faire
connaître sa réponse rapide si vous en
êtes d'accord sur la question des
déserts médicaux je rassure tout de
suite nous plus avons prévu une
organisation logistique stratégique qui
permettra de couvrir l'ensemble des
ehpad établissement pour personnes âgées
du territoire national en métropole et
en outre-mer nous n'avons pas assez
quand c'est des choses quand ça ne veut
pas dire que tout le monde travaille
sinon évidemment le même jour vous
comprenez bien que dix mille
établissements nécessite d'avoir des
équipes mais l'ensemble du territoire
doit être couvert lorsque nous passerons
à l'étape en médecine de ville
s'il ya lieu notamment d'aider des
personnes âgées qui ne pourraient pas se
déplacer facilement
nous avons d'ores et déjà reçu l'aide la
profession des deux collectivités comme
les régions par exemple mais nous avons
aussi la possibilité d'avoir des équipes
mobiles tout cela fait partie de la
stratégie je dirais de rang 2 non pas
parce que ce serait moins important que
le rend le rang 1
mais parce que ça vient un peu plus tard
dans la campagne vaccinale
s'agissant de l'approvisionnement en
vaccins il est territorialisée il est
réalisé au prorata des populations à
vacciner
j'ai parlé de 100 établissements de
santé il ya également une dizaine de
plateformes de stockage de vaccin dont
vont partir des véhicules qui ont
l'habitude de transporter des produits
de santé y compris dans des conditions
je dirais draconiennes comme des
conditions très froides que pour le
vaccin
eiser by one tech qui va ensuite aller
sur des plateformes logistiques de
pharmacie puis dans les pharmacies ce
qu'on sait faire cela ce qui est
différent c'est que la conservation à
moins 80 degrés à partir moment on
décongèle on reconstitue le produit pour
en faire le vaccin alors on a un nombre
de jours limité pour pouvoir vacciner
avec le conditionnement fait que les
vaccins seront par 5 ou par dix dans un
même flacon selon les vaccins considérés
ce qui nécessite évidemment d'avoir
aussi cela en tête en terme de deux
chantiers d'enjeux logistique
vous imaginez bien qu'on ne se lance pas
dans la campagne vaccinale sans avoir
anticipé toutes ces réflexions
la vaccination sera non obligatoire pour
tous je les dis en plus s'agissant des
personnes résidentes en ehpad
non seulement on va s'assurer que les
personnes soient consentantes pour la
vaccination après les avoir
informer leur avoir expliqué vérifier
qu'il n'y avait pas de contre
indications mais en plus si une personne
en ehpad n'est pas en état de donner son
consentement
de par son état de santé sa fragilité
notamment cognitive alors on s'attachera
à informer la famille à recueillir le
consentement de l'entourage proche comme
on a l'habitude de le faire pour
médecine n'est pas de lieu d'imaginer
une seconde qu'on avait traité
humainement différemment les personnes
selon qu'elle soit on n'est pas d'eau
qu'elle ne le soit pas si vous aviez une
interrogation je vous rassure
et puis sur la question du pilotage le
premier ministre l'a rappelé je pilote
situe le pilote interministériel de la
stratégie de vaccination contre le coc
vide de sécurisation des conditions son
déploiement opérationnel sur le
territoire pour cela je m'appuie sur une
équipe inter-ministérielle que je
remercie qui mobilisait depuis des mois
cette équipe est animée par monsieur
vieux sac est inspecteur général des
affaires sociales c'est une équipe qui
n'a pas de rôle décisionnel ni dans les
commandes
encore moins dans les achats de vaccins
qui n'a pas de rôle non plus
scientifique mais qui a un rôle
logistique notamment les étapes dont
nous avons parlé c'est à dire
identification des centres en france
dans lesquels stocker les vaccins le
matériel nécessaire pour la préparation
des vaccins je vous fais grâce des
détails sur la graduation des micros
seringue et le calibrage des aiguilles
mais tout cela nécessite évidemment un
travail logistique c'est une équipe qui
opèrent en cela sous ma responsabilité
au ministère de la santé et le
professeur fisher a été présenté comme
le président du comité d'orientation de
la stratégie vaccinale en charge des
questions scientifiques
donc voilà les choses sont très claires
allez on emprunte deux questions de plus
et on s'arrête
bonjour et une bonne est pour lci tf1
vous parliez de transparence et de
donner confiance aux citoyens allez-vous
vous monsieur le premier ministre et les
membres du gouvernement vous faire
vacciner pour montrer l'exemple et
autres questions sans lien avec la
situation sanitaire pour vous monsieur
le premier ministre on a appris hier
soir le décès du président valéry
giscard d'estaing
quelle image je conservais vous
conserverez vous
de lui à titre personnel pour mediapart
j'aimerais savoir pour quelles raisons
vous avait exclu les centres de
vaccination que ça a été le choix de
l'allemagne qui ont certes mauvaise
réputation depuis la campagne de 2009
mais qui ont peut-être
l' avantage d'efficacité vu les
contraintes logistiques et la deuxième
question c'est j'aimerais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus sur le
dispositif de pharmacovigilance
renforcée pardon sur la possibilité de
voilà de d'identifier les effets
indésirables graves le plus rapidement
possible et d'agir vite voilà allez une
dernière question
bon juste and leur dénier france info
pardon à propos de des bardes homme qui
avait été utilisé en 2009 lors de la
vaccination de la grippe h1n1 est ce que
vous envisagez ce même type de procédé
quand on sera à la phase 3 de
vaccination de la population dans son
ensemble est une question sur les
réticences et les peurs contre ces
vaccins on a bien compris le message de
dire que ça sera validée
scientifiquement et secure etc
mais est-ce que ça suffira et est-ce que
s'appuyer sur les médecins généralistes
fait partie de votre stratégie notamment
en les formant aussi et en les informant
bien et précisément
est ce qu'il ya une sorte de vade mecum
adressée aux médecins généralistes pour
qu'ils sachent quoi dire à leur passion
qui ne manquons pas de question précise
bien pendant que le ministre de la santé
nous rejoint parce que les les questions
sont essentiellement pour lui je vous
dirais juste que s'agissant là des
débats renommée de ce qui s'était passé
par le passé parce que vous avez bien vu
que la commande ya nous devons être
absolument pas pour la phase une à la
fois parce que c'est la plus proche et
surtout parce que nous avons un vaccin
et qui présente des caractéristiques
très particulières
je pense que pour ce qui est des phases
ii et iii à la fois raison des nouveaux
types de vaccins qui vous ont été
présentés qui arriveront et de la masse
de personnes à vacciner
nous allons affiner les dispositifs
c'est à dire je veux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui 3 décembre que nous allons
fixer exactement est ce qu'on aura pas
du tout deux barnums en mai ce serait
vous le comprendrez tout à fait ridicule
de notre parcours mais le
ministre va va compléter puis je je
répandrai l'eau aux deux dernières
questions alors sur la question d'abord
pourquoi sied pas de vaccinodromes pour
qu'il n'y a pas de très très gros
centres dont serait éloigné les
populations potentiellement 250
kilomètres pour se faire vacciner dès
lors qu'on a dit qu'en plus on priorise
est d'abord l'étape 1 étant donné qu'on
vaccine en établissement collectif pour
personnes âgées la question ne se pose
pas la question se pose ensuite pour
l'étape 2 est-ce qu'il faut avoir des
grands centres vague de vaccination on
est encore on sera encore
vraisemblablement en hiver on va
demander à des gens de 75 ans et plus de
venir faire la queue devant des centres
de réaliser souvent une grande distance
certains pays ont fait le choix d'avoir
des vaccinodromes enfin 50 vaccinodromes
à l'échelle du pays
imaginez les distances qu'il y aurait à
parcourir est ce que ça représente
ça n'a pas été un gain des sicav
d'efficacité en france d'autres pays
avait peut-être eu plus de résultats en
cela nous faisons le choix et la plupart
à l'immense majorité des pays autour de
nous font le choix des circuits de
vaccination que nous connaissons pour
lesquelles nous avons de l'expérience de
l' expertise en nous appuyant sur les
experts que sont les médecins et
notamment les médecins traitants c'est
la clé de la confiance
nous savons que les français font
confiance à leur médecin et c'est là où
les médecins sont exclus d'une campagne
vaccinale
la confiance est exclu nous les
associons et ce n'est pas la seule
raison évidemment c'est aussi parce que
nous voulons que les personnes puissent
être vaccinés dans des bonnes conditions
donc avec des éléments qui sont connus
ce qui n'exclut pas d'avoir des petits
centres de vaccination en lien
d'ailleurs avec les collectivités
territoriales qui peuvent proposer
d'identifier des endroits dans lesquels
des médecins pourrait venir ou d'autres
professionnels pourrait venir participer
à la vaccination
ça viendra peut-être plus tard rien
n'est exclu nous en discutons avec les
collectivités territoriales de manière
très ouverte et transparente mais encore
une fois nous avons un réseau qu'est
solide qui était prouvée de la même
manière nous avons en matière de
pharmacovigilance
un réseau qui est solide et quitte
éprouvé depuis des années des décennies
en lien avec l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui est en charge
du recueil des effets indésirables en
lien avec les médecins avec les
pharmaciens avec les infirmières qui
sont au contact des personnes qui ont
été vaccinées
croyez moi
il y aura une surveillance très
particulière avec un dispositif complet
en matière de recueil de toutes les
informations qui sont indispensables
lorsque on utilise un vaccin ou un
produit de santé d'ailleurs quels qu'ils
soient et qu'on met sur le marché un
type de médicaments comme celui ci et
nous mettrons en plus en transparence
ces informations à disposition du public
j'imagine que d'autres pays autour de
nous ferons la même chose nous avons une
histoire particulière en france autour
de la pharmacovigilance est un point
essentiel de la stratégie vaccinale que
nous conduisons quant à savoir si
monsieur premier ministre voudra se
faire vacciner je vais vous laisser
oui c'est vrai que c'est une question
piège mais c'est une question
intéressante c'est à dire que je vais
d'abord là où vous me croire sur parole
je ne figure pas dans les publics peur
et air déterminé par la has a fait je
dois je le crois pas bon et donc vous
voyez bien le premier inconvénient c'est
que si je suivais votre recommandation
d'aucuns pourrait qu'on sait que c'est
un passe droit
bon c'est pas dans les habitudes de la
maison mais je pense pas que ce soit ce
que vous me suggériez c'est plutôt sur
le terrain de l'exemplarité au sens
effet d'entraînement c'est vrai que
c'est je vous avoue que je ne me suis
pas posé la question à ces termes
bon jeu je pense qu'il faut quand même
suivre notre stratégie vaccinale et que
les premiers responsables du pays
doivent s'y conformer
ce que je fais en tout en toutes
circonstances alors quand au présent
giscard d'estaing je me suis exprimée on
va dire officiellement au petit matin
dès que la nouvelle de son décès mais
m'est parvenue je les croisais une seule
fois dans ma vie mais pas du tout pour
prétendre que je connaissais puisque la
question que vous me posez un tour
personnel voyez moi je suis né en 1935
donc le septennat de valéry giscard
d'estaing correspond à mon âme en éveil
à la vie publique a mon éveil à la
citoyenneté
je n'avais pas encore l'occasion de
voter même
s'il a abaissé l'âge de la majorité
électorale et c'était quelqu'un qui
quand j'étais plus jeune donc me
fascinait par par son intelligence son
aisance et sa jeune avait sans doute à
l'époque pas pas conscience que j'ai
évidemment aujourd'hui de ce qu'il a
apporté à notre pays
il est longtemps resté associé au
présent de la crise puisque comme vous
le savez son élection 1974 correspond au
premier choc pétrolier qui suit le
second la dégradation du du chômage et
c'est bon à laquelle il a fait face de
façon absolument déterminé mais voilà je
pense que j'ai dix tomes de liberté il
symbolisait cette grande tendance
libérale de la france à laquelle il a
apporté là non plus je ne vous
rappellerait pas les grands de loi qu'il
a fait voter je parlais des jeunes on
peut parler on peut parler des femmes je
vous rappelle aussi que c'est lui qui a
autorisé la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel par l'opposition s'était
à l'époque une réforme comme toujours
dont on a peu parlé et qui a eu pourtant
sur l' équilibre de nos institutions en
effet tout à fait significatif et puis
je le revois je garde l'image de de
l'européen je revois très bien la
campagne la première campagne au
parlement européen avec la figure
emblématique de simone veil qui l'avait
choisi pour la pour la conduire jeu je
le revois beaucoup avec le chancelier
helmut schmidt faisant l'europe
monétaire
s'inscrivant je dirais peut-être même
donna ses lettres de noblesse à ce
couple franco-allemand que qui lui a
largement survécu 1 jusque encore
aujourd'hui entre le présent macro mais
la chancelière prenant cette initiative
remarquée de la relance européenne voilà
c'est un peu un peu le père de tous à
valéry giscard d'estaing un homme
intelligent élégant un homme d'état donc
je vais j'essaie de m'en inspirer
voilà c'est sans doute le meilleur
hommage qu'on puisse lui rendre
je vous remercie beaucoup